Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join thegiastic, lesbian, incestuous and bloodthirsty. A poisoner and an infanticide, Marie Antoinette tried her hand at every crime. Through her wickednesses, she caused the revolution. She ruined the country, brought the people to despair, drove them to revolt. All must be revealed. It was from your lechery that our gothers were emptied to pay for your pleasures. So declared the anonymous author of The Cause of the French Revolution, or The Secret Conduct of Marie Antoinette of Austria, Queen of France, published in 1790.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入我们。淫乱、女同性恋、乱伦且嗜血。玛丽·安托瓦内特（Marie Antoinette）是个投毒者，也是个杀婴者，她尝试过各种罪行。通过她的邪恶行径，她引发了革命。她毁了国家，使人民陷入绝望，驱使他们反抗。一切都必须揭露。正是因为你的淫乱，我们的粮仓才被掏空来供你享乐。这是1790年出版的《法国大革命的起因》或《奥地利的玛丽·安托瓦内特，法国王后的秘密行径》一书的匿名作者所宣称的。
After having brought about the fall of the Ancien Régime, she struggled to preserve it. She was corruption personified, infinitely decadent. So that was Chantal Thomas in La Reine Celerate, The Wicked Queen, her biography, her account of Marie Antoinette through the eyes of the propaganda against her, Tom. And what a way to kick off our great new series
在导致旧制度（Ancien Régime）垮台后，她又竭力维护它。她是腐败的化身，极其颓废。以上是尚塔尔·托马斯（Chantal Thomas）在她的传记《邪恶王后》（La Reine Célérate）中所述，这是她通过针对玛丽·安托瓦内特的宣传视角所做的叙述，汤姆。而以这种方式开启我们伟大的新系列真是太棒了。
on the French Revolution than with libertinism, orgiastic behavior. Yeah, incest, bloodthirstiness. Brilliant. Everything we associate with French history. And the perfect way for us, Tom, on The Rest is History, to greet the beginning of the Paris Olympics.
关于法国大革命，还有什么比从放荡主义、淫乱行为开始更好的呢？是的，乱伦、嗜血。太精彩了。所有我们与法国历史联系在一起的东西。对于我们《历史的余味》来说，这是迎接巴黎奥运会开幕的绝佳方式，汤姆。
Absolutely. So, yeah, the eyes of the world are on Paris and France. So how better for us to contribute a series on what is probably, Dominic, I mean, one of the great seismic events, not just in European, but in global history. Certainly one of the two or three greatest stories in world history. I mean, the rollercoaster of bloodshed, violence, utopianism, insurrection, excitement, you name it. In fact, such a terrific story, Tom, that we're going to take at least two series, probably three series,
绝对是这样。所以，是的，全世界的目光都聚焦在巴黎和法国。那么，我们贡献一个关于多米尼克（Dominic）所说的——我认为，这不仅是欧洲历史上，也是全球历史上最伟大的地震性事件之一的系列节目，还有什么比这更好的呢？这无疑是世界历史上最伟大的两三个故事之一。我的意思是，流血、暴力、乌托邦主义、起义、兴奋的过山车，应有尽有。事实上，这是一个非常精彩的故事，汤姆，我们将至少用两个系列，可能三个系列，
to do it justice, aren't we? So this is the kickoff for our first series, which will take us through the first couple of years of the revolution. Yeah. So we're going to look at some of the causes, some of the background to the revolution, and then we'll take through the storming of the Bastille and go up to the point where the king, Louis XVI, and his queen, Marie Antoinette, who we've just been hearing about, try to get out of France.
来公正地讲述它，不是吗？所以这是我们第一个系列的开端，它将带我们了解革命最初的几年。是的。所以我们将审视革命的一些起因、一些背景，然后我们将讲述攻占巴士底狱，一直讲到国王路易十六（Louis XVI）和他的王后玛丽·安托瓦内特（我们刚才提到的那位）试图逃离法国的那一刻。
And spoiler alert, they fail. And that is the cliffhanger on which we will leave it. Yeah. Because, of course, everybody knows what will then happen to the king and queen. Yes. And I think Marie Antoinette is a kind of wonderful focus for looking at some of the causes. I mean, she's one of the instantly kind of recognisable figures. She must be one of the two or three most well-known people in all French history, I would have
剧透预警，他们失败了。这就是我们将要留下的悬念。是的。因为当然，每个人都知道接下来国王和王后会发生什么。是的。而且我认为玛丽·安托瓦内特是审视革命起因的一个绝佳焦点。我的意思是，她是那种一眼就能认出来的人物。她一定是法国历史上最著名的两三个人之一，我会这么说。
said. Yes. And as that kind of bravura passage that you quoted from Chantal Thomas's wonderful book suggests, at the time, she is seen by enthusiasts for the revolution as the absolute embodiment of everything that prompted it. You know, she is kind of the incarnation of ancien regime, arrogance, of aristocratic splendour, and of a kind of quality of vampirism that has leeched the French people of what should be rightfully theirs. You know, so in her lifetime before, and then particularly after the revolution,
是的。正如你引用的尚塔尔·托马斯那本精彩著作中的那段华丽段落所暗示的那样，在当时，她被革命的热衷者视为引发革命的一切事物的绝对化身。你知道，她是旧制度傲慢、贵族辉煌以及某种吸血鬼特质的化身，这种特质吸干了法国人民本应属于他们的东西。你知道，所以在她生前，特别是在革命之后，
she is the object of absolutely kind of obsessive hatred. And it's also a kind of prurient hatred, you know, because it is tied up with kind of fantasies about what she's been getting up to. And I guess that, I mean, that runs through to the present day because the one phrase that everyone would associate with her, let them eat cake, is still repeated, isn't it? Yeah. Despite the fact that she never said it. She never said it. I know. The original phrase is, Qu'il mange de la brioche.
她成为了绝对的、某种强迫性仇恨的对象。而且这还是一种淫秽的仇恨，你知道，因为它与关于她所作所为的幻想联系在一起。我想，这一直延续到今天，因为每个人都会与她联系在一起的那句话——“让他们吃蛋糕吧”（let them eat cake），至今仍在被重复，不是吗？是的。尽管事实上她从未说过。她从未说过。我知道。原话是“Qu'il mange de la brioche”。
So let me brioche. Has slightly different connotations, doesn't it? Yeah, because I always kind of imagine, you know, a big gato with kind of strawberries on the top or something. But she never said it anyway, so there's no point in dissecting it, I guess, to some degree, other than the fact that people think she said it is indicative of this idea of her and Louis,
所以“吃布里欧修面包”。这有稍微不同的含义，不是吗？是的，因为我总是想象，你知道，一个上面有草莓之类的大蛋糕。但无论如何她从未说过，所以我猜在某种程度上剖析它没有意义，除了人们认为她说过这句话，这表明了她和路易的这种形象，
who's supposedly kind of a puppet, then living this life of unbelievable depravity and licentiousness and arrogance and not caring. All of which, well, not all of it is completely wrong, but there are definitely huge problems with that. Nuances. Yeah. Against that, against the image of Marie Antoinette as a kind of depraved vampire. There's also been, right from the beginning, for conservatives, a sense that she is the archetype of the victims
路易被认为是某种傀儡，然后过着令人难以置信的堕落、放荡和傲慢的生活，并且毫不在意。所有这些，嗯，并非完全错误，但其中肯定存在巨大的问题。细微差别。是的。与玛丽·安托瓦内特作为某种堕落吸血鬼的形象相对立的，从一开始，对于保守派来说，就有一种感觉，认为她是革命受害者的原型。
of the revolution. Her fate exemplifies what critics of the revolution see as its destructiveness, as its kind of bloodlust. So the revolution itself is cast as a vampire. And in England, the person who classically first articulates that is the Irish politician and Whig, so not even a Tory, Edmund Burke, who November 1790 wrote Reflections on the Revolution in France. And in that, he famously recalls seeing Marie Antoinette kind of 16 or 17 years before at the court, glittering like the morning star full of life and splendor and joy. And he famously enthuses, I thought 10,000 swords must have leaped from their scabbards to avenge even a look that threatened her with insult. But the age of chivalry is gone, that of sophistas, economists and calculators has succeeded and the glory of
她的命运体现了革命批评者所认为的破坏性，以及它那种嗜血的本性。所以革命本身被塑造成了一个吸血鬼。在英国，第一个经典地阐述这一点的人是爱尔兰政治家和辉格党人（甚至不是托利党人）埃德蒙·伯克（Edmund Burke），他在1790年11月写了《对法国大革命的反思》。在书中，他著名地回忆起16或17年前在宫廷中看到的玛丽·安托瓦内特，像晨星一样闪耀，充满生命、辉煌和欢乐。他著名地感叹道：“我以为会有1万把剑从鞘中跳出，去报复哪怕是一个威胁要侮辱她的眼神。但骑士时代已经过去，诡辩家、经济学家和计算者的时代已经接踵而至，欧洲的荣耀永远熄灭了。”
Europe is extinguished forever. Edmund Burke's, I would say, among biographers and among people who studied the revolution, it's his take actually that is more enduring than the let them eat cake, she's a vampire school of thought, isn't it? Because actually now, I would say most writers are filled with horror when they look at what happened to Marie Antoinette, this young girl who arrived in France and was turned into a hate figure for the mob. Chantal Thomas, who we opened with, her book is about the vituperation that is kind of lashed on Marie Antoinette. And she has a section where she talks about how biographers through the 19th and into the 20th century would debate about whether
埃德蒙·伯克的观点，我想在传记作者和研究革命的人中，实际上比“让他们吃蛋糕吧”、她是吸血鬼的学派更持久，不是吗？因为实际上现在，我想大多数作家在看到玛丽·安托瓦内特的遭遇时都充满了恐惧，这个来到法国并被变成暴民仇恨对象的年轻女孩。我们开篇提到的尚塔尔·托马斯，她的书是关于对玛丽·安托瓦内特那种谩骂的。她有一个章节讨论了19世纪到20世纪的传记作者如何争论这些故事是否真实。
these were true or not. And she just says, you know, none of these stories about the incest and the vampirism are true. I mean, they're obviously not true. And she says that most recent biographies have been written, to quote her, with sympathy, if not with love. And I would say that's probably true of her as well, because she wrote a novel that then got turned into a film called Farewell, My Queen in English that featured Diane Kruger, so Helen of Troy in Troy, as Marie Antoinette. And that's a French film. But of course, Marie Antoinette has also been a kind of an American pinup. So a film that was massively popular with my daughters when they were growing up, came out in 2006, is Sophia Coppola's Marie Antoinette. Kirsten Dunst. In which she's kind of cast as, you know, very much a contemporary heroine. She's surrounded
而她只是说，你知道，所有关于乱伦和吸血鬼的故事都不是真的。我的意思是，它们显然不是真的。她说最近的大多数传记都是用同情，如果不是用爱来写的。我想这对她来说可能也是真的，因为她写了一部小说，后来被拍成了电影，英文名叫《再见，我的王后》（Farewell, My Queen），由黛安·克鲁格（Diane Kruger，即《特洛伊》中的海伦）饰演玛丽·安托瓦内特。那是一部法国电影。但当然，玛丽·安托瓦内特也一直是一种美国海报女郎。所以，一部在我的女儿们成长过程中非常受欢迎的电影，2006年上映的索菲亚·科波拉（Sophia Coppola）的《玛丽·安托瓦内特》，由克尔斯滕·邓斯特（Kirsten Dunst）主演。在片中，她被塑造成一个非常现代的女主角。她被她的闺蜜团包围，
by her squad. She's got converse trainers in the cabinet. You know, she rushes around Versailles to new wave bands. And what was interesting about that, I was kind of reading up about the reception of it in France because it was premiered at Cannes. And there it was greeted with boos and then with cheers. So kind of answering boos and cheers by the French journalists who'd been watching it, which I guess kind of sums up a massive division in France itself about her. Because Marion Tornet stands for the revolution to some degree, because what you think of Marion which I guess kind of sums up a massive division in France itself about her. Because Marie Antoinette stands for the revolution to some degree, because what you think of Marie Antoinette,
她在内阁里穿着匡威运动鞋。你知道，她在凡尔赛宫里伴随着新浪潮乐队的音乐奔跑。有趣的是，我读过关于它在法国的评价，因为它是在戛纳首映的。在那里，它受到了嘘声，然后是欢呼声。所以，观看它的法国记者们发出的嘘声和欢呼声，我想这总结了法国国内关于她的大规模分歧。因为玛丽·安托瓦内特在某种程度上代表了革命，因为你对玛丽·安托瓦内特的看法，
you know, you ask an educated Frenchman or Frenchwoman what they think of Marie Antoinette, and their answer will tell you, well, they think of the revolution probably, and probably also where they stand politically even today in the 21st century, don't you think? I mean, I do. And i think to a degree that may be true as well in the broader world perhaps a bit i mean it's much more focused in france obviously and i think that that sense of ambivalence you know is marie antoinette a monster or is she a victim is she someone to be detested and loathed or is she someone to be pitied and admired that's an ambivalence that is there even before the revolution so the way that she is viewed by the french public is a kind of mixture of loathing and desire yeah because she's not always hated that's an important point to make no you know she's very popular with certain segments of society and I think that she's cast either as a kind of emblem of royal grace, because as we will
你知道，你问一个受过教育的法国男人或女人他们对玛丽·安托瓦内特的看法，他们的回答会告诉你，嗯，他们可能会想到革命，也可能想到即使在21世纪，他们在政治上的立场，你不觉得吗？我的意思是，我确实这么认为。而且我认为在某种程度上，这在更广阔的世界里可能也是真实的。我的意思是，它在法国显然更集中，而且我认为那种矛盾感，你知道，玛丽·安托瓦内特是一个怪物还是一个受害者？她是应该被憎恶和厌恶的人，还是应该被怜悯和钦佩的人？这种矛盾感在革命之前就存在了。所以法国公众看待她的方式是一种厌恶和欲望的混合体。是的，因为她并不总是被憎恨，这是一个重要的观点。不，你知道，她在社会某些阶层中非常受欢迎，我认为她要么被塑造成皇家优雅的象征，因为正如我们将要
see, in a way, she's a very, very modern figure. Yeah, completely. She kind of basically, I think, invents the French ideal of fashion. She's way ahead of the game. But to other people, this makes her the embodiment of frivolity or decadence. And she's a very proactive queen. Queens in France generally are not expected to play a proactive role in court life, still less national life. Marie Antoinette comes to do that. And she's a kind of emblem of all the paradoxes that we'll be talking about in the context of the revolution. And the fact that she's a figure of fantasy is really crucial because not just her, but the revolution itself is about the creation of stories, the projection of stories and narratives onto facts of the economy, agriculture, the crowds, the court, everything. It's how you structure the story that basically determines your attitudes to the revolution, I think. Totally agree, Tom. I mean, historians like Simon Sharma and Robert Danton have written
看到的，在某种程度上，她是一个非常、非常现代的人物。是的，完全是。她基本上，我认为，发明了法国的时尚理想。她遥遥领先。但对其他人来说，这使她成为轻浮或颓废的化身。她是一位非常积极主动的王后。法国的王后通常不被期望在宫廷生活中发挥积极作用，更不用说在国家生活中了。玛丽·安托瓦内特做到了这一点。她是我们将要在革命背景下讨论的所有悖论的象征。而且她是幻想人物这一事实非常关键，因为不仅是她，革命本身就是关于创造故事，将故事和叙事投射到经济、农业、人群、宫廷等事实之上。我认为，你如何构建这个故事，基本上决定了你对革命的态度。完全同意，汤姆。我的意思是，像西蒙·沙玛（Simon Sharma）和罗伯特·丹顿（Robert Darnton）这样的历史学家写过
brilliant books about how the French Revolution is a sort of hall of mirrors or a hall of narratives, I suppose. Very appropriate for Versailles, isn't it? Yeah. So let's start not at Versailles, but with Marie Antoinette herself. So she is born, Tom, in 1755. And of course, the single most important thing about her, I would say, is that she is not French. She is Austrian. We love the Habsburgs on The Rest Is History. I don't think there'll ever be a historical podcast in the history of mankind that is so keen on the Habsburgs as The Rest Is History. We've had Edward Habsburg talking about the Habsburgs. We've had Franz Ferdinand, a great friend of The rest of history, and now another Habsburg,
精彩的书，关于法国大革命如何是一个镜厅或叙事厅。这对凡尔赛宫来说非常贴切，不是吗？是的。那么让我们不要从凡尔赛宫开始，而是从玛丽·安托瓦内特本人开始。所以她出生于1755年，汤姆。当然，关于她最重要的一点，我会说，是她不是法国人。她是奥地利人。我们在《历史的余味》中热爱哈布斯堡家族。我不认为人类历史上会有任何历史播客像《历史的余味》这样热衷于哈布斯堡家族。我们有爱德华·哈布斯堡（Edward Habsburg）谈论哈布斯堡家族。我们有弗朗茨·斐迪南（Franz Ferdinand），《历史的余味》的好朋友，现在又是另一位哈布斯堡，
Marie Antoinette. Yes, although she's born Maria Antonia. And I think that it's fair to say that her identity as an Austrian and as a Habsburg is kind of fundamental both to how her admirers see her and how her detractors see her. So to her admirers, she is an embodiment of a new age of peace between what traditionally have been the great rivals in European politics. So going right the way back to the 16th century, Charles V and François I, these are the people who are kind of tearing Europe up while Luther is busy getting on with his stuff. And France and the Habsburg Empire have been the great geopolitical rivals on the continent of Europe. But this has changed over the course of the 18th century due to the emergence of two new great powers. One of those is Britain, very happy to say. So in the Seven Years' War,
玛丽·安托瓦内特。是的，尽管她出生时叫玛丽亚·安东尼娅（Maria Antonia）。我认为可以公平地说，她作为奥地利人和哈布斯堡人的身份，对于她的崇拜者和诋毁者看待她的方式都是根本性的。所以对她的崇拜者来说，她是欧洲政治中传统上两大竞争对手之间和平新时代的化身。所以追溯到16世纪，查理五世（Charles V）和弗朗索瓦一世（François I），这些人是当路德忙于他的事情时撕裂欧洲的人。法国和哈布斯堡帝国一直是欧洲大陆上的地缘政治大国竞争对手。但这在18世纪随着两个新大国的出现而改变了。其中之一是英国，我很高兴地说。所以在七年战争中，
Britain is taking on France and winning as a kind of global power. But on the continent, there's the emergence of Prussia. Prussia is hungry for a lot of Austria's traditional territories. Under its great king, Frederick II, it annexes a province called Silesia, doesn't it? It's basically now a chunk of Poland. The Habsburgs are terribly upset about this. Basically, they enter into an alliance with France so that they can get Silesia back. France enters into an alliance with France so that they can get Silesia back. And France enters into an alliance with Austria so that she can have a counterweight to Britain. So the diplomatic revolution historians call this because it's such a seismic
英国正在对抗法国并获胜，作为一个全球大国。但在大陆上，普鲁士出现了。普鲁士渴望奥地利的大部分传统领土。在其伟大的国王腓特烈二世（Frederick II）的统治下，它吞并了一个叫西里西亚（Silesia）的省份，不是吗？它基本上现在是波兰的一大块。哈布斯堡家族对此非常难过。基本上，他们与法国结盟，以便夺回西里西亚。法国与奥地利结盟，以便拥有一个对抗英国的砝码。所以历史学家称之为外交革命，因为它在欧洲历史上是如此地震撼
moment in European history. Yeah. So the Seven Years' War breaks out in 1756 with Britain and Prussia against Austria and France. And the following year, a very heavyweight figure in French politics, the Duc de Choiseul arrives in Vienna as the French ambassador. And the rulers who greet him, they're a couple, aren't they? So the emperor is Francis I. But the person who's really kind of cracking the whip is his wife, the Empress Maria Theresa. And she is a very, very proficient politician. Indeed, one might say stateswoman, but she's also very, very proficient politician. Indeed, one might say stateswoman, but she's also very, very fertile. And the Habsburgs have always, I mean, it's been their
时刻。是的。所以七年战争于1756年爆发，英国和普鲁士对抗奥地利和法国。第二年，法国政坛的一位重量级人物舒瓦瑟尔公爵（Duc de Choiseul）作为法国大使抵达维也纳。迎接他的统治者是一对夫妇，不是吗？所以皇帝是弗朗茨一世（Francis I）。但真正掌权的是他的妻子，玛丽亚·特蕾莎（Maria Theresa）女皇。她是一位非常、非常精明的政治家。事实上，人们可能会说她是女政治家，但她也非常、非常多产。哈布斯堡家族一直以来，我的意思是，这一直是他们的
boast, isn't it? That some empires get their way by fighting. We do it by marrying off our children. Yep. And Maria Antonia is their 11th daughter and as it will turn out, their last daughter. And the reason that the Duke de. Chazelle is interested in her is that she is one year younger than the grandson of Louis XV, the French king, also inevitably called Louis. And his very fertile mind is thinking, well, you know, we could maybe marry them off. A brilliant way to cement the alliance and to ensure that the alliance endures.
吹嘘，不是吗？有些帝国通过战斗来达到目的。我们通过嫁女儿来做到。是的。玛丽亚·安东尼娅是他们的第11个女儿，事实证明，也是他们的最后一个女儿。舒瓦瑟尔公爵对她感兴趣的原因是，她比法国国王路易十五（Louis XV）的孙子（也不可避免地叫路易）小一岁。他那非常活跃的头脑在想，嗯，你知道，我们也许可以把他们嫁出去。这是巩固联盟并确保联盟持久的绝佳方式。
Yes. And so in due course, Chazelle goes back from Vienna. He goes back to Paris and he becomes the foreign minister, basically the kind of, almost the prime minister for Louis XV. And he's kind of pushing this idea. He's saying, we should really try and cement this alliance.
是的。于是，舒瓦瑟尔从维也纳回到了巴黎，他成为了外交大臣，基本上是路易十五的某种准首相。他一直在推动这个想法。他说，我们真的应该尝试巩固这个联盟。
And it comes into further focus in 1765 when Louis XV's son, and therefore the father of this Louis who is being lined up to marry Maria Antonia, he dies. And so the grandson of Louis XV is now the Dauphin, the kind of French equivalent to the Prince of Wales, the heir to the throne. And he's 11 and Maria Antonia is then 10. Yes. And on the 4th of April, 1770, it's all agreed. The marriage contract is signed. There's a kind of weird thing where they do a proxy marriage in Vienna. Yeah.
在1765年，当路易十五的儿子，也就是这个被安排与玛丽亚·安东尼娅结婚的路易的父亲去世时，这一点变得更加突出。所以路易十五的孙子现在是王储（Dauphin），相当于法国的威尔士亲王，王位的继承人。他11岁，玛丽亚·安东尼娅当时10岁。是的。1770年4月4日，一切都商定好了。婚约签署了。有一种奇怪的事情，他们在维也纳举行了代理婚姻。是的。
So the new emperor, Maria Theresa's son, Joseph, he stands in for the Dauphin. And then two days later, Maria Antonia is put into a carriage, along with 56 other carriages. And they set off from Vienna to go to France. And people who are enthusiasts for this alliance think this is brilliant. Absolutely wonderful. But of course, in France, there are lots of people who are not enthusiasts because as you said, I mean, these are ancestral enemies. They have, of course, come together under the pressure of Prussia and Britain. But culturally, imaginatively, the idea of Austria to most French men and women is this horrendous place, our enemies. The Austrians can't be trusted. And that baggage,
所以新皇帝，玛丽亚·特蕾莎的儿子约瑟夫（Joseph），代表王储。两天后，玛丽亚·安东尼娅被送进了一辆马车，连同其他56辆马车。他们从维也纳出发前往法国。这个联盟的热衷者认为这太棒了。绝对美妙。但当然，在法国，有很多人并不热衷，因为正如你所说，我的意思是，这些是世仇。他们当然在普鲁士和英国的压力下走到了一起。但在文化上、想象中，奥地利对大多数法国男人和女人来说是一个可怕的地方，我们的敌人。奥地利人不可信。而那种包袱，
she is never able to shed it for the rest of her life. So right the way through her career and to an escalating degree, she is always referred to as le trichienne, so the Austrian. But if you put the emphasis on chienne, that's bitch in France. Yeah, of course. So it's the kind of the ostrich bitch. So she's always being portrayed either as an ostrich or as a dog or both. And the weird thing is, is that this isn't actually remotely fair because her father is basically French. So Francis I, he's the Duke of Lorraine.
她余生都无法摆脱。所以贯穿她的整个职业生涯，并且程度不断升级，她总是被称为“l'autrichienne”，即“奥地利女人”。但如果你强调“chienne”，在法国那是“母狗”的意思。是的，当然。所以它是某种“奥地利母狗”。所以她总是被描绘成一只鸵鸟或一只狗，或者两者兼而有之。奇怪的是，这实际上一点也不公平，因为她的父亲基本上是法国人。所以弗朗茨一世，他是洛林公爵。
He is of French royal descent. And there's a case for saying that Marie Antoinette is actually one of the most French queens that the Bourbon, the royal dynasty, have ever had. Because normally, they're marrying foreign queens who have no French connections at all. But what's interesting is that her father basically gets written out of the story, and she is portrayed as being her mother's daughter, solely her mother's daughter. Maria Theresa is seen as this terrifying virago who is out to destroy France. And so, Marie Antoinette is cast as a kind of Trojan horse who's been sent into the very stronghold of French power to destroy it from inside.
他有法国王室血统。有一种说法是，玛丽·安托瓦内特实际上是波旁王朝有史以来最法国化的王后之一。因为通常情况下，他们娶的是完全没有法国血缘关系的外国王后。但有趣的是，她的父亲基本上被从故事中抹去了，她被描绘成她母亲的女儿，仅仅是她母亲的女儿。玛丽亚·特蕾莎被视为这个可怕的悍妇，一心想摧毁法国。因此，玛丽·安托瓦内特被塑造成某种特洛伊木马，被送进了法国权力的堡垒，从内部摧毁它。
In Simon Sharma's words, the spy whore, he says that's the, I mean, we're jumping ahead, but that's the image that people later have of her. Yes. And Maria Antonia, she really does become Marie Antoinette. So actually French has been her first language. She speaks it initially with a German accent, but she very rapidly loses that. And in preparation for her life at the French court, she's had a French tutor called the Abbe de Vermont, who turns up and is appalled to discover that Marie Antoinette, basically, she hasn't had any education at all. And throughout her life, she has no interest in books. She's not remotely intellectual yeah although
用西蒙·沙玛的话说，“间谍妓女”，他说那是，我的意思是，我们跳得太快了，但那是人们后来对她的形象。是的。玛丽亚·安东尼娅确实变成了玛丽·安托瓦内特。所以实际上法语一直是她的第一语言。她最初说法语时带有德国口音，但她很快就改掉了。为了准备她在法国宫廷的生活，她有一位名叫维尔蒙神父（Abbe de Vermont）的法国导师，他出现后震惊地发现玛丽·安托瓦内特基本上根本没有受过任何教育。而且她一生对书本都没有兴趣。她一点也不知性，是的，虽然
she is interested in kind of the cultural temperature isn't she yeah she is but it's said of her that no one has ever seen her finish a book and i think that that is kind of widely believed and he complains of a quality that will be repeatedly applied to her which is her legere her frivolity her lightness the fact that she is not a heavy person. Yeah. I think it would be fair to say. But he also acknowledges that, you know, she has great charm. She has great poise. She is also not conventionally pretty because she has, you know, the classic protuberant lower lip of a Habsburg. But she, you know, she has, the Abbe says,
她对某种文化温度感兴趣，不是吗？是的，她是，但人们说她从未见过她读完一本书，我认为这被广泛相信。他抱怨了一种会被反复应用到她身上的特质，那就是她的“légèreté”，她的轻浮，她的轻盈，事实上她不是一个沉重的人。是的。我想说这很公平。但他同时也承认，你知道，她有很大的魅力。她有很大的风度。她也不是传统意义上的漂亮，因为她有，你知道，哈布斯堡家族经典的突出的下唇。但她，你知道，神父说，
a perfect porcelain complexion. She has brilliant blue eyes. She has a very sweet oval face. So basically, you know, she will do. Robert D'Arnson in his book, The Revolutionary Temper, says that when the pamphleteers, newspapers and whatnot, were talking about her in France, they all said, she's actually very nice looking. You know, she's blonde hair, beautiful pale complexion. She looks like a queen. She does. And as we will see, she becomes a great icon of beauty and fashion and style.
她有完美的瓷器般的肤色。她有明亮的蓝眼睛。她有一张非常甜美的椭圆形脸。所以基本上，你知道，她会成功的。罗伯特·丹顿在他的书《革命气质》（The Revolutionary Temper）中说，当法国的小册子作者、报纸等等谈论她时，他们都说，她实际上看起来非常好。你知道，她有金色的头发，美丽的苍白肤色。她看起来像个王后。她确实是。正如我们将要看到的，她成为了美丽、时尚和风格的伟大偶像。
And there's a kind of symbolic moment where she ceases to be Austrian and becomes French, which is, you know, she's traveling up from Vienna with her 57 carriages. And on the 7th of May, 1770, they reach the Rhine and there's an island in the middle of it. And this wooden pavilion has been built that looks like a kind of, you know, perfectly tiny chateau. And it has five rooms inside it. And there's two on the Austrian side, two on the French side, and there's a kind of room in the middle. And Marion Tournette goes into the Austrian rooms.
有一个象征性的时刻，她不再是奥地利人，而变成了法国人，那就是，你知道，她带着她的57辆马车从维也纳赶来。1770年5月7日，他们到达了莱茵河，河中间有一个岛。这个木制凉亭建得看起来像某种，你知道，完美的微型城堡。里面有五个房间。奥地利一侧有两个，法国一侧有两个，中间有一个房间。玛丽·安托瓦内特进入了奥地利房间。
She's divested of her clothes, down to her kind of underwear. She's then put into a French ceremonial dress. She's led into the central drawing room. The door leading into the French rooms is opened. She looks back. The Austrian doors have been shut. All the Austrian servants have vanished. And Marion Tournette is handed over to this terrifying woman, who is the maitresse d'etiquette, the woman who is going to instruct her in the ritual of the court, called the Comtesse de Neuilly. What was that noise? Comtesse de Noy. Noy. Yeah, it's just too many vowels. There's basically four vowels in that. Noy. Scrabble heaven. Yeah, it is. And Marie Antoinette bursts into tears at the sight of this terrifying woman, flings herself into the Comtesse's arms.
她被脱掉衣服，只剩下内衣。然后她被换上了法国礼服。她被带进中央客厅。通往法国房间的门打开了。她回头看。奥地利房间的门已经关上了。所有的奥地利仆人都消失了。玛丽·安托瓦内特被交给了这个可怕的女人，她是礼仪女官（maitresse d'etiquette），那个将要在宫廷仪式上指导她的女人，叫诺伊伯爵夫人（Comtesse de Noailles）。那是什么声音？诺伊伯爵夫人。诺伊。是的，元音太多了。基本上有四个元音。诺伊。拼字游戏的天堂。是的，确实。玛丽·安托瓦内特看到这个可怕的女人时泪流满面，扑进了伯爵夫人的怀里。
The Comtesse, massively embarrassed, very stiff, shrugs her off, performs a low curtsy. Marie Antoinette apologises and says, pardon me, these are for the family in the fatherland I'm leaving. For the future, I shall not forget that I am French. And the Comtesse de Neuilly says, yeah, you better not. I'm here to whip you into shape. So off they go. And Tom, just one thing. She is 14 years old. She's not yet 15. Imagine what an unbelievably terrifying moment this must be for her. And what makes it even worse, she has an adorable little dog who she has to leave behind, but we'll come to that later. It's a crucial part of the story. Anyway, on they rattle, and it takes them a week to meet with the Dauphin and the French king. And they do it outside the
伯爵夫人非常尴尬，非常僵硬，把她推开，行了一个深屈膝礼。玛丽·安托瓦内特道歉说：“原谅我，这些是为我离开的祖国的家人流的。从今往后，我不会忘记我是法国人。”诺伊伯爵夫人说：“是的，你最好别忘。我是来把你调教好的。”于是他们出发了。汤姆，只有一件事。她14岁。她还不到15岁。想象一下，这对她来说一定是一个令人难以置信的可怕时刻。更糟糕的是，她有一只可爱的小狗，她不得不把它留在后面，但我们稍后再谈。这是故事的关键部分。无论如何，他们摇摇晃晃地走着，花了一周时间才见到王储和法国国王。他们在贡比涅森林（forest of Compiègne）外见面。王储和王储妃（玛丽·安托瓦内特现在的身份）被介绍了。三天后，他们结婚了。她现在是法国王后。关于婚姻，汤姆，一个坏兆头，一个非常黑暗的兆头。任何了解俄罗斯历史的人，都会发现这种相似之处。尼古拉二世（Nicholas II）和亚历山德拉（Alexandra）加冕时，事后发生了大规模踩踏事件，数百人死亡。好吧，在王储和玛丽·安托瓦内特结婚后，又发生了一次踩踏事件。有一场烟花表演出了大问题。
forest of Compiègne. And the Dauphin and the Dauphine, as Marie Antoinette now is, are introduced. Three days later, they are married. And she is now the Queen of France. Just on the marriage, Tom, one bad omen, one very dark omen. Anyone who knows about Russian history, they will spot the resemblance. Nicholas II and Alexandra, when they were crowned, there was a massive stampede afterwards and hundreds of people were killed. Well, after the marriage of the Dauphin and Marion Tornet, there was another stampede. There's a fireworks display that goes horribly wrong.
也许有150人在拥挤中丧生。烟花不是掉进帐篷里了吗？对，没错。有两个竞争的烟花设计师，一个叫托雷先生（Monsieur Torre），一个叫鲁杰里（Ruggeri）。鲁杰里排在第二，所以他想胜过那个家伙。这是一场极其复杂的烟花表演。它出了问题。烟花掉到了他建造的那个神庙上，海门神庙（temple of Hymen）。
Perhaps 150 people were killed in the crush. And doesn't a firework kind of drop onto a tent? Right, exactly. There were two rival fireworks designers, a man called Monsieur Torre and a guy called Ruggeri. And Ruggeri goes second, so he wants to outdo the other bloke. It's an incredibly elaborate fireworks display. It goes wrong. A firework falls onto this temple that he's built, a temple of Hymen.
在拥挤中，150人丧生。所以每当人们后来回顾时，他们都会说，从一开始就注定了，多么糟糕的预兆。我们本不该和这个奥地利女人扯上关系。你知道，烟花是一个警告。是的。有一种伟大的象征，不是吗，法国的纹章和哈布斯堡家族的纹章交织在一起。正如你所说，它引发了这场灾难，被视为一种预兆。
And in the crush, 150 people are killed. And so whenever people look back later on, they say, doomed from the start, what a bad omen. We should never have got involved with this Austrian woman. You know, the fireworks were a warning. Yeah. There's kind of great emblem, isn't there, kind of the arms of France and the arms of the Habsburgs intertwined. The fact that it has generated this disaster, as you say, is seen as an omen.
我认为这反映了一个事实，即法国人不仅讨厌奥地利人，而且有点看不起他们，因为奥地利相对于法国自16世纪以来一直在衰落。法国现在，除了俄罗斯，是迄今为止最大的欧洲王国。在18世纪，它被描述为欧洲的中国。它拥有迄今为止最大的人口。2800万。是的。是英国的两倍。
I think that that reflects the fact that the French don't only hate the Austrians, but kind of look down on them because Austria relative to France has been declining since the 16th century. France now is, with the exception of Russia, by far the largest European realm. In the 18th century, it's been described as the China of Europe. It has by far the largest population. 28 million. Yeah. Twice as big as Britain.
即使加上爱尔兰。是的。所以它拥有地缘政治力量。它拥有人口，正如你所说，它拥有巨大的文化声望。当然，这种文化声望的伟大象征就是玛丽·安托瓦内特去过的地方，也是她将度过余生大部分时间的地方，那就是巨大的凡尔赛宫。那是他们结婚的地方，这座巨大的宫殿，大约有700个房间，2000扇窗户，屋顶覆盖了100公顷。
And Britain even with Ireland. Yeah. So it has geopolitical power. It has population, as you said, and it has massive cultural prestige. And of course, the great symbol of this cultural prestige is the place where Marie Antoinette has gone and where she will spend much of her life, which is the enormous Palace of Versailles. It's where they're married, this enormous palace, kind of 700 rooms, 2000 windows, the roofs cover 100 hectares.
我的意思是，规模巨大。它基本上是法国君主制所代表的政府风格的物理体现，这是一种君主专制。我的意思是，法国君主制一直很强大，但从16世纪，然后通过17世纪，绝对进入18世纪，它越来越垄断权力。当然，体现这一点的形象是路易十五的曾祖父和前任，路易十四（Louis XIV），他基本上消灭了作为独立政治阶级的贵族。他要求他们来到凡尔赛宫，他们只是围绕太阳运行的行星。是的。太阳王。
I mean, on an enormous scale. And it's basically the physical embodiment of the style of government that the French monarchy represents, which is a kind of monarchical absolutism. I mean, the French monarchy had always been powerful, but since the 16th and then through the 17th and definitely into the 18th century, it's monopolized power more and more. And of course, the figure who exemplifies that is the great grandfather of Louis the 15th and predecessor, Louis the 14th, who had basically annihilated the nobility as an independent political class. He had required them to come to Versailles and they are merely planets orbiting the sun. Yeah. Sun King.
太阳王。所以凡尔赛宫为整个欧洲设定了时尚、礼仪、一切。所以路易十四的伟大竞争对手马尔博罗公爵（Duke of Marlborough），通过建造某种替代的凡尔赛宫来庆祝他对路易十四的胜利。是的。布伦海姆宫（Blenheim Palace）。布伦海姆宫。但我认为对于玛丽·安托瓦内特，实际上对于几乎所有人来说，我的意思是，这是一个非常压抑的地方，不是吗？太可怕了。所以她在哈布斯堡宫廷长大，那里更非正式，而且在她童年时期变得越来越非正式。但法国宫廷，我的意思是，这部分是因为它受到这些非常、非常严格的仪式等级规则的约束。
The sun King. And so Versailles sets fashion, manners, everything for the whole of Europe. So the great rival of Louis XIV, the Duke of Marlborough, he celebrates his victories over Louis XIV by building a kind of ersatz Versailles. Yeah. Blenheim Palace. Blenheim Palace. But I think that for Marie Antoinette and indeed pretty much for everybody, I mean, it's a very oppressive place, isn't it? It's awful. So she's grown up in the Habsburg court, which is much more informal and is becoming more informal during her childhood. But the French court, I mean, it's partly because it's governed by these very, very strict ceremonial hierarchical rules.
但它也是一个政治蛇穴，不是吗？人们一直在争夺权力。是的。玛丽·安托瓦内特的问题之一是，她的赞助人舒瓦瑟尔公爵在婚后几个月就失势了。他一直是她的赞助人、她的保护者。这意味着她只是一个非常年轻的女孩，十几岁，她被那些讨厌她和讨厌奥地利的人包围着。所以王储的姑姑们，也就是路易十五的女儿们，她们讨厌奥地利。此外，王储还有弟弟，特别是其中一个，普罗旺斯伯爵（Comte de Provence），他在未来很久之后（我慎重使用“很久”这个词）将成为路易十八（Louis XVIII）。
But also it is a kind of snake pit of politics, isn't it? With people jostling for power the whole time. Yes. And one of the problems for Marie Antoinette is that her patron, Dr. Choisel, falls from power only a few months after her marriage. And he'd been her sponsor, her protector. And that means that she's just a very young girl, teenager, and she's surrounded by people who hate her and hate Austria. So the aunts of the Dauphin, so Louis XV's daughters, they hate Austria. Also, the Dauphin has younger brothers, and one in particular, the Comte de Provence, who in due course, vastly in the future, and I use the word vastly advisedly, will become Louis XVIII.
我的意思是，一个体型巨大的人。但在这一点上，他还很年轻。他自己只是个十几岁的孩子，但他对不能成为国王的事实感到愤恨。是的。所以他是一个潜在的蛇。一个变成蛇的弟弟，这在君主制历史上再也不会发生了，是吗，汤姆？再也不会了。我认为在这个系列中，我们将梳理出一些与当代王室成员的相似之处。所以可怜的玛丽·安托瓦内特感到完全被孤立，她抱怨她所有的信件都被查看，她锁住的任何地方都不安全。我的意思是，这是所有外国王后在
I mean, a man of colossal size. But at this point, he's still very young. He's just a teenager himself, but he's consumed with resentment of the fact that he's not going to be king. Yeah. So he's a potential snake. A younger brother who turns out to be a snake. That will never happen in monarchical history again, will it, Tom? Never again. There are certain parallels to contemporary royals that we'll be teasing out over the course of this series, I think. So poor Marie Antoinette feels completely cut off, and she complains that all her correspondence is being looked at, that nowhere that she locks anything is safe. I mean, this is the kind of treatment that all foreign queens in
凡尔赛宫所经历的待遇。她们在那里既是人质也是其他任何东西。她们不被期望过得开心。她们不被期望享受生活。但玛丽·安托瓦内特，她足够坚强。从一开始就很清楚，她是一个比她丈夫坚强得多的人物。而且很清楚，当她成为王后时，她将反抗这种形式主义。所以有一个经典的时刻，因为某种原因她骑在驴上。我想这是一个十几岁的女孩可能会喜欢做的事情，但伯爵夫人非常不赞成。所以她从驴上摔了下来，她开了一个机智的玩笑，说她最好去问问伯爵夫人，王储妃从驴上摔下来的礼仪是什么。
Versailles put through. They are kind of there as hostages as much as anything else. And they're not expected to have a good time. They're not expected to enjoy themselves. But Marie Antoinette, she's strong enough. And right from the beginning, it's clear that she's a much stronger character than her husband. And it's clear that when she becomes queen, she is going to kick back against this kind of formality. So there's a kind of classic moment where for some reason she's riding on a donkey. It's the kind of thing I guess a teenage girl might enjoy doing, but that the Comtester really disapproves of. So she falls off the donkey and she kind of makes this witty quip that she'd better send to the Comtesse to find out what the etiquette is for a Dauphine falling
你可以看到，这是一种将与凡尔赛宫运作方式相抵触的态度。然而，话虽如此，她对那种形式主义和僵硬感到愤恨。还有一个事实是，凡尔赛宫，特别是在路易十五统治下，是皇家放荡行为的某种令人不安的展示。因为路易十五，虽然个人是一个相当谦虚和害羞的人，但他也是一个有点肮脏的老头。我的意思是，从早到晚，他只想着一件事。当他被告知玛丽·安托瓦内特的存在时，他说的第一句话难道不是“她有大胸部吗”？不，那是她到达时，哦，对了，当她到达时，他说的第一句话是“她有大胸部吗”？我的意思是，这太失礼了，
off a donkey. And you can see there that this is an attitude that is going to rub up against a lot that has made Versailles tick. However, having said that, that she's resentful of the kind of the formality and the stiffness of it all. There is also the fact that Versailles, particularly under Louis XV, is a kind of showcase for unsettling displays of royal libertinism. Because Louis XV, although personally quite a kind of modest and shy person, he's a bit of a dirty old man as well. I mean, from morning till night, he only ever thinks about one thing. Is it not true that the first thing he said when he was told about Marieion tonette's existence no it's when she's arrived oh right when she's arrived and the first thing he says is does she have large breasts i mean that is that's bad form
而且得知她没有，他很失望。从你的岳父那里，你不想听到这个，对吧？不，他一直是个喜欢情妇的人，他有一位非常著名的情妇蓬帕杜夫人（Madame de Pompadour），但她已经去世了，新的情妇，杜巴利伯爵夫人（Comtesse du Barry），她被提升到那个头衔，她是一个前交际花。她有，我的意思是，这是一种半正式的头衔，即“正式情妇”（Maîtresse en Titre）。但玛丽·安托瓦内特对此感到震惊。你知道，她从小就是虔诚的天主教徒。在维也纳没有这样的事情。所以她通过拒绝与杜巴利伯爵夫人说话来挑战宫廷礼仪。她的母亲玛丽亚·特蕾莎对此非常愤怒，因为她试图让法国
and it's disappointed to learn that she doesn't from your father-in-law you don't want to hear it do you no and he's been a great man for mistresses he had a very celebrated mistress madame du pompadour but she's gone and the new new mistress, the Comtesse du Barry, who's been elevated to that title, she's a kind of former courtesan. And she has, I mean, it's a kind of semi-formal title, the Maîtresse en Titre. But Marie-Antoinette is appalled by this. You know, she's been raised a devout Catholic. There's nothing like this in Vienna. And so she defies court protocol by refusing to even speak to the Comtesse du Barry. And Maria Theresa, her mother, is furious about this because she's trying to get France
支持她在波兰领土争端中的立场。她说：“听着，你必须和杜巴利夫人说话。你知道，我需要你这样做。”所以玛丽·安托瓦内特最终还是做了。她对杜巴利夫人说：“今天凡尔赛宫有很多人。”然后是一阵欢呼。万岁！是的。
to back her in a kind of dispute over a chunk of Poland. And she says, look, you've got to talk to Madame du Barry. You know, I need you to do this. So Marie Antoinette does eventually. And she says to Madame du Barry, there are many people at Versailles today. And there's great cheering. Hurrah! Yeah.
大坝决堤了。是的。她再也没说过别的话。好吧。但幸运的是，对于玛丽·安托瓦内特来说，杜巴利夫人和路易十五都没有活太久，因为1774年4月27日，路易十五病倒了。流言会说杜巴利夫人据称给他找了一个年轻的农家女孩。侍从把这个农家女孩带了进来，结果发现这个农家女孩患有天花。
The dam is broken. Yeah. She never says anything else. Okay. But fortunately for Marie Antoinette, neither Madame du Barry nor Louis XV are long for the world because on the 27th of April, 1774, Louis XV falls ill. And gossip will say Madame du Barry has supposedly sourced a young peasant girl for him. And the valet has brought this peasant girl in and the peasant girl turns out to have had smallpox.
所以他的整张脸最终变成了一大块化脓的脓疱，有人说那是“被结痂放大的青铜面具”。我的天，那太好了。所以你刚才说的那个，流言蜚语，这非常、非常重要，因为这是一个宫廷与巴黎以及法国其他地区隔绝的时代。所以大多数人通过流言蜚语了解国王和王后。这是一个有小册子、民谣的时代。这是一种以前从未真正存在过的、非常识字、非常新闻友好的社会。而且多米尼克，更重要的是，你说它是密封的。我的意思是，它在某种程度上是，但在另一方面它不是，因为凡尔赛宫的所有不同派系都在泄露东西。所以关于王后的丑闻故事，以及在未来，
And so his whole face ends up a great superating mass of pustules, a bronze mask enlarged by the crusts is what it said. Oh my word, that's nice. So that thing that you just said there, gossip has it or rumour has it, that's really, really important because this is an age where the court is kind of hermetically sealed off from Paris and therefore from the rest of France. And so most people learn about the king and queen through rumour and gossip. And this is an age when there are pamphlets, ballads. It's a very literate, very news-friendly society in a way that has not really existed before. And Dominic, what is more is that you say that it's hermetically sealed. I mean, it kind of is in one way, but in another way it isn't because all the different factions in Versailles are leaking stuff. So the scandalous stories that are told about the Queen and in due
于是他的整张脸最终变成了一大团化脓的脓疱，书中写道，那是一张被结痂放大的青铜面具。天哪，这描述真不错。你刚才提到的那句“据传闻”或“有流言说”，这一点非常非常重要，因为在那个时代，宫廷与巴黎乃至整个法国几乎是隔绝的。所以大多数人都是通过流言蜚语来了解国王和王后的。那是一个小册子和歌谣盛行的时代，社会识字率很高，对新闻非常热衷，这种程度在以前是从未有过的。多米尼克，更重要的是，你说它是完全封闭的。我的意思是，从某种程度上看确实如此，但从另一方面看又并非如此，因为凡尔赛宫里的各个派系都在泄露消息。所以关于王后的那些丑闻故事，在适当的时候
course about Marie Antoinette, these are not coming from disgruntled Republicans. They're coming from power players at the very heart of the court, often from the royal family itself. So the wellspring of all the gossip and slander that will overwhelm Marie Antoinette in the period of the revolution has been established by Versailles itself. Anyway, so whether Louis XV is dying because he's been brought, you know, a peasant girl by his mistress or not is up for grabs. But what is clear is that on the 10th of May, 1774, he dies. The news is brought to the Dauphin and there's kind of amazing descriptions of how the sound of the news being brought to him and of people running to come and tell him.
关于玛丽·安托瓦内特的课程，这些言论并非来自心怀不满的共和党人。它们来自宫廷核心的权势人物，甚至往往来自王室本身。因此，在革命时期将玛丽·安托瓦内特淹没的所有流言蜚语和诽谤，其源头正是凡尔赛宫自己。总之，路易十五是否因为情妇给他送来一个农家女而垂死，这尚无定论。但可以确定的是，1774年5月10日，他去世了。消息传到了王储耳中，关于消息传达给他时以及人们奔走相告时的声音，有着令人惊叹的描述。
It's like a kind of swelling tidal wave. The king is dead. Long live the king. And the Dauphin is with Marie Antoinette. Of course, he's no longer the dauphin he's now louis the 16th and there are various accounts of what they say when they're told the news but the most celebrated one is that they fall to their knees and cry out may god guide and protect us for we are too young to reign because they were 18 and 19 something like that
这就像一股汹涌的浪潮。国王驾崩了。国王万岁。王储当时正和玛丽·安托瓦内特在一起。当然，他不再是王储，他现在是路易十六了。关于他们听到消息时的反应有各种说法，但最著名的是他们跪倒在地，大喊：“愿上帝指引并保护我们，因为我们太年轻，无法统治。”因为他们当时分别才18岁和19岁左右。
and i think they're aware that france faces massive problems but marie antoinette later writes to maria theres her mother, and says, I cannot refrain from admiring the workings of Providence, which has chosen me, the youngest of your children, to occupy the finest throne in Europe. But the question is, Dominic, what will she do with that power? Well, we'll find out, Tom, after the break. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix
我想他们意识到法国面临着巨大的问题，但玛丽·安托瓦内特后来写信给她的母亲玛丽亚·特蕾莎说：“我无法不钦佩天意的安排，它选择了我，您最小的孩子，来占据欧洲最美好的王位。”但问题是，多米尼克，她将如何运用那份权力呢？好吧，汤姆，休息之后我们再来揭晓。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》，这是你们每周的固定节目。
of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched
包含娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了
our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com that's therestisentertainment dot com.
我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前购买现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com，网址是 therestisentertainment 点 com。
Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Anyone could see that Marie Antoinette would dominate the new king. So says John Hardman in his book Marie Antoinette's The Making of a French Queen. Now that idea that Louis XVI, who of course is a very ill-fated king, because as most of our listeners will know, he ends up having an appointment with the guillotine. Is it fair to
欢迎回到《剩下的就是历史》。任何人都能看出玛丽·安托瓦内特会主导这位新国王。约翰·哈德曼在他的书《玛丽·安托瓦内特：一位法国王后的诞生》中这样写道。现在，关于路易十六——当然他是一位命运多舛的国王，因为正如我们大多数听众所知，他最终被送上了断头台——这个观点，是否公平地
say, Tom, that he is merely her puppet? He is a weaker man, isn't he, than Marie Antoinette? Let's talk about their relationship a bit. Do they get on? Are they a happy couple, would you say? There are significant incompatibilities. So we could just go through some of them. So one is attitudes to music. Marie Antoinette is very, very musical. She can play the harp. She can play the harpsichord. She can play the flute. Her brother, Joseph II, who is ruling along with Maria Theresa, his mother, is the great patron of Mozart. Marie Antoinette had met Mozart when they were six years old. Imagine meeting Mozart and you're the same age. You'd feel so inadequate, wouldn't you? I know. And so she is very, very musical.
说，汤姆，他仅仅是她的傀儡？他确实比玛丽·安托瓦内特软弱，不是吗？让我们谈谈他们的关系。他们相处得好吗？你会说他们是一对幸福的夫妻吗？他们之间存在严重的不兼容。我们可以列举一些。首先是对音乐的态度。玛丽·安托瓦内特非常有音乐天赋。她会弹竖琴，会弹大键琴，会吹长笛。她的哥哥约瑟夫二世，与母亲玛丽亚·特蕾莎共同执政，是莫扎特伟大的赞助人。玛丽·安托瓦内特在六岁时就见过莫扎特。想象一下，你和莫扎特同岁，却见到了他。你会感到非常自卑，不是吗？我知道。所以她非常有音乐天赋。
Louis XVI is notoriously hostile to the arts and to music in particular. And this becomes a kind of topic of gossip. So in the pamphlets, people laugh at him for his lack of musicality. He's like a British culture secretary. Yes, he is. That's exactly what he is. No knowledge of the arts or interest in any music or anything like that. He might once have seen Star Wars, but that would be the limit of his cultural engagement.
路易十六以对艺术，特别是对音乐的敌意而闻名。这成了一个八卦话题。因此，在小册子里，人们嘲笑他缺乏音乐素养。他就像一位英国文化大臣。是的，他正是那样的人。对艺术一窍不通，对任何音乐或其他类似事物毫无兴趣。他可能曾经看过《星球大战》，但这大概就是他文化参与的极限了。
And then, of course, we mentioned the dog that Marie Antoinette was not allowed to bring into France because it was an Austrian dog. This dog was called Mops and it was a pug. And this, I think, is basically what makes her burst into tears and fall onto the bosom of the Comtesse de Noy. It's being deprived of the dog. But listeners will be glad and relieved to know that she does in due course get reunited with mops. So that's happy. Louis hates dogs. And more particularly, I'm sad to say, as a cat owner, he hates cats. He's right in that regard, but hating dogs is madness it's madness cats are rubbish no he's not he's absolutely not because he takes it to an unacceptable degree which is so as a dauphin his favorite activity was to shoot cats love it on the roofs of versailles
然后，当然，我们提到了玛丽·安托瓦内特不被允许带入法国的那只狗，因为它是一只奥地利狗。这只狗叫莫普斯，是一只哈巴狗。我认为，这基本上就是让她泪流满面并倒在诺伊伯爵夫人怀里的原因。就是因为失去了这只狗。但听众们会感到高兴和欣慰的是，她最终还是与莫普斯团聚了。所以这很圆满。路易讨厌狗。更具体地说，我很遗憾地说，作为一名猫主人，他讨厌猫。他在这一点上是对的，但讨厌狗简直是疯了，这太疯狂了，猫才是垃圾。不，他不是，他绝对不是，因为他做得太过分了。作为王储时，他最喜欢的活动是在凡尔赛宫的屋顶上射杀猫，他很喜欢。
my wife is allergic to cats so she would very much approve of that tom basically he's shooting strays yeah and this apparently is acceptable for sport in Versailles. But he accidentally shoots the Angora cat of the Comtesse de Meurepoix. And when he does this, he's actually very upset and he apologises profusely. And I think it's a story that does sum up an aspect of his character, which is that on one level, he's very heedless of the suffering, whether of cats or of people out in the fields of La France Profonde. On another level, when he's informed of individual examples of suffering, he's very upset about it and worried about it. I think you're too harsh, though. I don't think he's any more heedless than anybody
我妻子对猫过敏，所以她会非常赞同这一点，汤姆。基本上他是在射杀流浪猫。是的，这在凡尔赛宫显然是可以接受的运动。但他不小心射杀了德·默勒波伊伯爵夫人的安哥拉猫。当他这样做时，他其实非常难过，并连连道歉。我认为这个故事总结了他性格的一个方面，即在某种程度上，他非常无视痛苦，无论是猫的痛苦，还是法国深处田野里人们的痛苦。在另一方面，当他被告知具体的痛苦案例时，他会感到非常难过和担忧。我觉得你太苛刻了，我不认为他比任何
else sealed off in the Palace of Versailles would be. Right. But I think if you're shooting stray cats, I mean, you just assume this is the kind of thing that a king does or it's an acceptable sport. Yeah. But when it's brought home to him what the implications are, then he worries about it. And I think you could say the same about his relationship to the broader troubles out in France, that he's not aware of it until he's informed about it. And then he doesn't really know what to do. I guess so. He's not casual about it.
被封锁在凡尔赛宫里的其他人更无视痛苦。对。但我认为如果你在射杀流浪猫，我的意思是，你只会认为这是国王做的事情，或者这是一种可以接受的运动。是的。但当他意识到这意味着什么时，他就会感到担忧。我认为关于他与法国更广泛的困境之间的关系，也可以这么说，即在被告知之前，他并不知情。然后他真的不知道该怎么办。我想是这样。他对此并不随意。
He's perhaps slightly oblivious to it. Yeah. His big thing is hunting, isn't it? We've had two tremendous huntsmen on the rest of history recently, Franz Ferdinand and the Kaiser. And Custer. That would be a brilliant hunting party with those four men. Because Louis XVI is a tremendous huntsman.
他可能对此稍微有点健忘。是的。他最热衷的是狩猎，不是吗？我们最近在《剩下的就是历史》中谈到了两位伟大的猎人，弗朗茨·斐迪南大公和德皇。还有卡斯特。那四个人组成的狩猎队会非常精彩。因为路易十六是一位了不起的猎人。
He absolutely adores it. And he keeps a journal where he writes down how many animals he's killed. So the famous thing that everybody says on the day of the fall of the Bastille in 1789, that he wrote in his journal, rien, as in nothing happened today. That's rubbish. Actually, the nothing was because he hadn't killed any animals that day. So a very disappointing day. I mean, I think it's also fair to say that he's not a great diarist. So on the day he meets Marie Antoinette, he says, met mademoiselle la dauphine. And the day his mother dies, he says, my mother died. Okay. Like Camus l'étranger, my mother died today or yesterday.
他绝对热爱狩猎。他记了一本日志，记录他杀死了多少动物。所以每个人在1789年巴士底狱陷落那天都说的那句名言，他在日志里写了“rien”，意思是今天什么都没发生。那是胡说八道。实际上，那个“什么都没有”是因为他那天没有杀死任何动物。所以那是令人非常失望的一天。我的意思是，我认为公平地说，他也不是一个出色的日记作者。所以在他见到玛丽·安托瓦内特的那天，他写道：“见到了王储妃殿下”。在他母亲去世的那天，他写道：“我母亲去世了”。好吧。就像加缪的《局外人》，“今天我母亲去世了，或者昨天”。
I don't remember. It's obviously a French tradition. Who knew? Yeah. Yeah. So he's not a great diarist. And as you said, he is a great huntsman, but I think that one of the reasons why he adores it so much is that he's very good at it. You know, he's a very good horseman, but when he's on his own two feet, he's incredibly kind of maladroit and socially as well as physically. So he hates dancing. He's not good at kind of chit chat. You know, all the stuff that people at Versailles are doing. He doesn't really like it. And basically he has the soul of a naval engineer.
我不记得了。这显然是法国的传统。谁知道呢？是啊。所以他不是一个出色的日记作者。正如你所说，他是一位伟大的猎人，但我认为他如此热爱狩猎的原因之一是他非常擅长。你知道，他是一位非常优秀的骑手，但当他双脚着地时，他在社交和身体上都非常笨拙。所以他讨厌跳舞。他不擅长闲聊。你知道，凡尔赛宫的人都在做的那种事。他其实并不喜欢。基本上他拥有一个海军工程师的灵魂。
So he loves fleets. He loves harbours. And he loves tinkering with locks. You know, he has his own workshop. Oh, I love this stuff. Simon Sharma is brilliant on this. So he's got this study, hasn't he? With all these maps and nautical instruments, and he'll just sit there with a lock, like messing around, you know, surrounded by all this stuff. He's like a tinkering inventor. And actually, I think that comes over as quite endearing. louis xvi is doing was a symbol of sublime aptness for the monarch who repeatedly failed to make things turn as he wished but in his appartement privy he moved silently in his plain frock coat
所以他热爱舰队。他热爱港口。他热爱摆弄锁具。你知道，他有自己的工作室。哦，我喜欢这些。西蒙·沙马在这方面非常出色。所以他有这个书房，不是吗？里面有各种地图和航海仪器，他就会坐在那里摆弄一把锁，你知道，被所有这些东西包围着。他就像一个爱摆弄的发明家。实际上，我认为这显得相当可爱。路易十六所做的，对于这位反复未能如愿让事情好转的君主来说，是一种崇高契合的象征，但在他的私人公寓里，他穿着朴素的礼服，在
amidst polished lenses armillary spheres burnished brass and orries with all the freedom and power of omegas oh i love that it's so good isn't it i mean let me just say one thing right at the outset for those people who haven't read it or have maybe heard about it and just can't be bothered through it because it's quite long simon shama's book citizens is insanely enjoyable it's just i mean i know it's it's always tempting to be revisionist and to say of a great historian and a great book that's actually rubbish it is tip-top it is brilliant and has great pictures as well it does yeah so marianne tonette would have enjoyed that yes she would she would have looked at the pictures that's nice but dominic just to say that there is an alternative perspective on this yeah which is the perspective of pamphleteers one of
抛光的透镜、浑天仪、磨光的黄铜和太阳系仪中静静地移动，拥有着奥米茄般的所有自由和力量。哦，我喜欢这个，太棒了，不是吗？我的意思是，我首先要说一件事，对于那些还没读过它，或者可能听说过它但因为书太厚而懒得读的人，西蒙·沙马的《公民》非常令人享受。我的意思是，我知道对于一位伟大的历史学家和一本伟大的书，总是很容易去修正主义地评价说那其实是垃圾，但它确实是一流的，非常出色，而且还有很棒的图片。确实是这样。所以玛丽·安托瓦内特会喜欢那本书的。是的，她会，她会看那些图片。那很好，但多米尼克，不得不说，对此还有另一种视角。是的，那就是小册子作者的视角，其中
whom describes him as a zombie who spends his time making locks and bolts and you may wonder well where is this tone coming from i think it's coming from the prince harry of versailles who is the comp de provence right who is consumed with envy and spleen. So he is feeding all kinds of kind of hostile material out to the pamphleteers. But I think it also reflects the fact that the ultimate incompatibility, it seems, certainly in the early years of the marriage, is sexual. And if there's one thing that a French king is supposed to do, it's to be sexually voracious. So it is better to be Louis XV, you know, an absolute goat.
一个人把他描述成一个只会花时间制造锁和螺栓的僵尸。你可能会想，这种语调是从哪里来的？我认为它来自凡尔赛宫的哈里王子，也就是普罗旺斯伯爵，对吧？他被嫉妒和怨恨所吞噬。所以他向小册子作者输送了各种敌对的材料。但我认为这也反映了一个事实，即这种终极的不兼容，似乎在婚姻的早期几年里，是性方面的。如果说法国国王应该做的一件事，那就是在性方面贪得无厌。所以最好是像路易十五那样，你知道，一个彻头彻尾的色鬼。
Who is this bloke's grandfather, by the way, just to clarify. Yeah, than to be sexually incompetent. Yeah. Which is clearly what Louis XVI is. And it takes them seven years to consummate the marriage. And there's much debate at the time, and there is much debate to this day
顺便澄清一下，这哥们是谁的祖父。是的，总比性无能要好。是的。这显然是路易十六的情况。他们花了七年时间才圆房。当时有很多争论，直到今天也有很多争论
about what the problem was. So a favoured thesis is that Louis XVI suffered from a condition called phimosis, which basically means that the foreskin covers the head of the penis, which means that erections become very painful. I think the consensus now, I gather, I don't quite know how they've arrived at this consensus, is that this isn't the case. Theo has written in the chat, thanks, Tom. And I'm sure many of the listeners are also very grateful to you
关于问题出在哪里。所以一个受青睐的论点是路易十六患有一种叫包茎的疾病，这基本上意味着包皮覆盖了阴茎头，这意味着勃起会变得非常痛苦。我想现在的共识是，我了解到，我不太清楚他们是如何达成这个共识的，但这并不是事实。西奥在聊天中写道，谢谢你，汤姆。我相信很多听众也非常感谢你
for that slightly unnecessary detail. It's not unnecessary because actually the question of why the king and queen are not having children is a matter of profound state. And as discussed, Tom, at the highest level.
提供了这个稍微有点不必要的细节。这不是不必要的，因为实际上国王和王后为什么没有孩子是一个重大的国家问题。正如所讨论的，汤姆，是在最高层面上。
So Joseph II, who is the emperor of Austria and who's Marie Antoinette's brother, she must have told him about it because he writes to another brother and says, I mean, I'm not going to go him about it because he writes to another brother and says, I mean, I'm not going to go into all the gory details, but he basically says,
所以约瑟夫二世，他是奥地利皇帝，也是玛丽·安托瓦内特的哥哥，她一定告诉过他这件事，因为他写信给另一个兄弟说，我的意思是，我不会去谈论所有血腥的细节，但他基本上说，
they do try to have marital relations. Louis, and I quote, stays there without moving for perhaps two minutes and then says goodnight, you know. Withdraws and says, okay. Yeah, I was omitting that detail. But it's important, isn't it? But anyway, he says goodnight.
他们确实尝试过夫妻生活。路易，我引用一下，“在那里待了大约两分钟，一动不动，然后说晚安”，你知道。撤退并说，好吧。是的，我刚才省略了那个细节。但这很重要，不是吗？但无论如何，他说晚安。
Thank you very much. All good. And they're not actually completing the necessary act. And basically they need doctors or courtiers or whoever to explain to them. Well, according to tradition, Joseph II makes that report after he's been on a trip to Versailles and he's spoken to both the king and the queen. Yeah. And the tradition is that he explains what needs to be
非常感谢。一切都好。他们实际上并没有完成必要的行为。基本上他们需要医生或朝臣或任何人来向他们解释。好吧，根据传统，约瑟夫二世是在去凡尔赛宫旅行并与国王和王后交谈后做出那份报告的。是的。而传统说法是，他向路易十六解释了需要
done to Louis XVI with reference to a lock and a key. Right. Yeah. He would enjoy the lock analogy. I just find the whole thing slightly implausible, but anyway. But there's no question that this makes him a kind of object of some contempt, which in many ways is unfair because I think you're right. He is dutiful. He is hardworking. He is conscientious. He does develop a reputation for kindness, maybe cats accepted. So Chantal Thomas writes, for a sovereign, the line between goodness and imbecility was easily crossed. And I think that Louis XVI is on that line, that people can admire him as a good man while simultaneously despising him as someone who is incompetent or useless as a sovereign.
做什么，并引用了锁和钥匙的例子。对。是的。他会喜欢这个锁的类比。我只是觉得整件事有点不可信，但无论如何。但毫无疑问，这使他成为某种蔑视的对象，这在很多方面是不公平的，因为我认为你是对的。他是尽职的。他是勤奋的。他是认真的。他确实建立了善良的声誉，也许猫除外。所以尚塔尔·托马斯写道：“对于一位君主来说，善良和愚蠢之间的界限很容易跨越。”我认为路易十六就在那条线上，人们可以钦佩他是一个好人，同时又鄙视他作为一个君主是无能或无用的。
He's not an impressive man. He's not a charismatic or formidable man. He doesn't inspire respect. He's probably quite a nice man, but a weak man. Is that fair, Tom? I think probably, yes. I think it's felt that he is not of royal material, really. But having said that, whether it's Joseph II or not, who manages to explain to him what he's got to do they do finally get together and uh marion trinette gives louis four children including crucially two sons so a dauphin and a spare yeah which is obviously very important and they end up you know quite a devoted couple yeah amazingly he doesn't take a mistress so on one level that of course only enhances the idea
他不是一个令人印象深刻的人。他不是一个有魅力或令人生畏的人。他不能激发尊重。他可能是一个相当不错的人，但却是一个软弱的人。这公平吗，汤姆？我想大概是的。我认为人们觉得他真的不是王室的料。但话虽如此，无论是不是约瑟夫二世成功向他解释了他该做什么，他们最终还是在一起了，而且玛丽·安托瓦内特为路易生了四个孩子，其中关键的是两个儿子，一个王储和一个备用，是的，这显然非常重要，他们最终成为了，你知道，相当恩爱的一对。是的，令人惊讶的是他没有找情妇。所以从一个层面来看，这当然只会增强人们对他的看法，
of him that he's he's not a kind of the libertine. He's not an alpha male. He's not an alpha male. But on another, he's kind of upholding an almost bourgeois standard of kind of marital fidelity. He banishes Madame du Barry, who gets packed off. And Madame du Barry, like Madame du Pompadour before her, had this splendid kind of grace and favour residence in the grounds of Versailles, kind of little chateau called the Petit Trianon.
即他不是那种浪子。他不是阿尔法男。他不是阿尔法男。但从另一方面来看，他是在维护一种近乎资产阶级的婚姻忠诚标准。他放逐了杜巴利夫人，她被打发走了。杜巴利夫人，像她之前的蓬帕杜夫人一样，在凡尔赛宫的庭院里有一处辉煌的恩宠住所，一种叫小特里亚农宫的小城堡。
And Louis gives this to Marie Antoinette. So now it's the Queen's and she absolutely loves it. You know, we've talked about how resentful and hostile she is to the kind of stifling etiquette of Versailles. The Petit Trianon offers her a bolt hole and it gives her the perfect opportunity to vent all her qualities of spontaneity and simplicity and impulse that she loves. So on that, you were saying about her not reading a book. Simon Sharma says in Citizens, like all adolescent girls of her generation, she drank deep at the well of sentimental literature. Her library was full of Samuel Richardson, Rousseau, Mercier, Restive de Breton, etc. Now, her library was full of them. Maybe she didn't necessarily read them but as shama says she is steeped in the culture that is the most modern fashionable forward-looking
路易把这个送给了玛丽·安托瓦内特。所以现在它是王后的了，她绝对喜欢它。你知道，我们谈论过她对凡尔赛宫那种令人窒息的礼仪是多么怨恨和敌视。小特里亚农宫为她提供了一个避难所，并给了她完美的空间来发泄她所热爱的所有自发性、简单和冲动的品质。所以关于你说的她不读书那点，西蒙·沙马在《公民》中说，像她那一代的所有青春期女孩一样，她深深地沉浸在感伤文学的源泉中。她的图书馆里装满了塞缪尔·理查森、卢梭、梅西耶、雷蒂夫·德·拉·布雷顿等人的书。现在，她的图书馆里装满了这些书。也许她不一定读过它们，但正如沙马所说，她沉浸在最现代、最时尚、最具前瞻性的文化中。
she's not stuck in the mud she's not a relic of the ancient regime she's interested particularly in the stuff that people associate with the philosopher the thinker russo which are virtue simplicity nature a sort of, as you said, spontaneity. Yeah. And these are all qualities that will come to be seen in due course as features of the revolution. Yeah.
她没有陷入泥潭，她不是旧制度的遗物，她特别对人们与哲学家、思想家卢梭联系在一起的东西感兴趣，即美德、简单、自然，一种正如你所说的，自发性。是的。而这些品质在适当的时候都将被视为革命的特征。是的。
But Marie Antoinette is a massive enthusiast for them. So much so that amazingly in 1782, she goes and visits Rousseau's grave outside Paris. So she's a kind of a pilgrim. You think she's picked up the ideas, but not read the books, basically? I don't know. I mean, she's probably skimmed through it. I think that's perfectly possible too, by the way. I mean, that's how most people actually pick up fashionable ideas, isn't it? These days, you pick them up on Facebook or in conversation, but you don't necessarily read the Wellspring. Yeah. And she is, for that reason, very, very fashionable because
但玛丽·安托瓦内特是这些东西的狂热爱好者。以至于令人惊讶的是，在1782年，她去参观了巴黎郊外的卢梭墓。所以她是一个朝圣者。你认为她只是领会了这些思想，但基本上没有读过那些书？我不知道。我的意思是，她可能浏览过。我认为这完全有可能，顺便说一句。我的意思是，这正是大多数人实际上领会时尚思想的方式，不是吗？这些天，你在Facebook上或在谈话中领会它们，但你不一定读过源头。是的。而且正因为如此，她非常非常时尚，因为
her lack of enthusiasm for fashion as prescribed by Versailles itself becomes the fashion. And the enthusiasm for Rousseau, the idea that one should lead a simple, unadorned life, and that this is the key to virtue. At the Petit Trianon, the emphasis is on hiding the presence of servants. So in Versailles, it's all about having as many servants as possible. You know, every time Marie Antoinette gets dressed, hundreds of maids surround her to do it. And the Petit Trianon is different. you know every time marie antoinette gets dressed hundreds of maids surround her to do it and the petit trianon is different and kind of famously she commissions a landscape architect to design
她对凡尔赛宫本身所规定的时尚缺乏热情，反而成了时尚。而对卢梭的热情，即一个人应该过一种简单、朴素的生活，而这是通往美德的关键。在小特里亚农宫，重点是隐藏仆人的存在。所以在凡尔赛宫，一切都是关于拥有尽可能多的仆人。你知道，每次玛丽·安托瓦内特穿衣时，数百名女仆围着她做这件事。而小特里亚农宫则不同。你知道每次玛丽·安托瓦内特穿衣时，数百名女仆围着她做这件事。而小特里亚农宫则不同，而且众所周知，她委托一位景观设计师为她设计
her an amouristique a kind of a rustic hamlet a rustic village that has cows with ribbons on alpine sheep a water mill and this of course, becomes notorious because it's the idea of a queen pretending to be a shepherdess that strikes up all kinds of unfortunate resonances. But, you know, she is the embodiment of fashion. But only notorious because the revolution happens. Yeah, I think so. You know, had France's finances been in better shape and there's no revolution. People would be charmed by this. Yeah. People would say it's an entertaining quirk of 18th century, you know, monarchical life. They wouldn't think anything of it. Yeah. And far from kind of saying that the poor should eat cake, she's very worried about the poor. Okay. I mean, the poor as
一个“乡村风格”的乡村小村庄，里面有系着丝带的奶牛、高山绵羊、水磨坊，这当然变得臭名昭著，因为王后假装成牧羊女的想法引发了各种不幸的共鸣。但是，你知道，她是时尚的化身。但只有在革命发生后才变得臭名昭著。是的，我想是这样。你知道，如果法国的财政状况更好，没有革命。人们会被这个所吸引。是的。人们会说这是18世纪君主生活中一种有趣的怪癖。他们不会多想。是的。而且她远非那种说穷人应该吃蛋糕的人，她非常关心穷人。好吧。我的意思是，穷人作为
kind of represented by photogenic paupers who can be given charity by her. She's the Angelina Jolie of the 18th century, Tom. Yes. So 1785, she lodges and feeds 12 poor families at the Petit Trianon. So she's very like a celebrity. Yeah. And there's a quality of the fact that I think she's very impressed
一种由上镜的贫民所代表的形象，可以由她施舍。她是18世纪的安吉丽娜·朱莉，汤姆。是的。所以1785年，她在小特里亚农宫安置并喂养了12个贫困家庭。所以她非常像一位名人。是的。而且我认为她对自己美德的感知非常深刻。对。她希望人们知道这一点，同时又确实对此感到担忧。我的意思是，所有这些事情
by the sense she has of her own virtue. Right. And she wants people to know about it while simultaneously genuinely being worried about it. I mean, all of those things
都可以是真的。当然。而且她想确保她的孩子们在这种环境中长大。她是一位非常非常好的母亲，一位非常细心的母亲。所以1784年，前一年，那是一个可怕的冬天。她为她的孩子们提供了她的一位同伴所描述的“行善的一课”，方法是带进一大堆玩具，然后说，你们不能拥有
can be true. Of course. And she wants to make sure that her children are raised in this. She's a very, very good mother, a very attentive mother. So 1784, the year before that, it had been a terrible winter. And she provides her children with what one of her companions describes as a lesson in doing good by bringing in a great kind of pile of toys and then saying, you can't have
这些，因为我们要卖掉这些玩具，用它们为贫困儿童换取毯子和面包。哦，这很令人惊讶。是的。非常像推特上的名人。我想这就是凯恩斯主义。是的。这也很凯恩斯主义。所以尚塔尔·托马斯对此有精彩的描述。她喜欢慈善，从不厌倦自己善良的奇观。所以我认为，她再次成为了某种现代名人类型的先驱，那种名人慈善。苏塞克斯公爵夫人，汤姆。是的，有一点那种特质。所以这是在道德层面上。
these because we're going to sell these toys and use them to get blankets and bread among children in need. Oh, that's quite surprising. Yeah. Very celebrity on Twitter. That's why it's a Kenzian, I think. Yeah. It's very to Kenzian. That as well. So Chantal Thomas describes this wonderfully. She was fond of charity and never tired of the spectacle of her own goodness. So I think, again, she is a precursor of a kind of modern type of celebrity there, kind of celebrity charity. The Duchess of Sussex, Tom. Yeah, a slight quality there. So that's on the kind of the moral level.
但她也创造了一种新的时尚，完全摒弃了凡尔赛宫那种僵硬的礼节。所以她有这位裁缝，罗斯·贝尔坦，令人震惊的是，她被允许随时进入她的公寓。她不需要经过所有通常限制人们见王后的宫廷礼仪。基本上，玛丽·安托瓦内特正在抛弃宫廷里所有昂贵的丝绸，换上飘逸的白色细棉布，换上简单的服装、鲜花、田园风格的装饰。
But she also creates this kind of new kind of fashion that is absolutely repudiating the kind of the stiff formality of Versailles. So she has this dressmaker, Rose Bertin, who shockingly is allowed ready access to her apartments. She doesn't go through all the court protocols that normally restricts people who can see the queen. And basically, Marie Antoinette is kind of discarding all the rich silks of the court for flowing white muslins, for kind of simple costumes, fresh flowers, kind of bucolic adornments.
对。不仅如此，她停止穿紧身胸衣和束腰，以及所有那些真正把你束缚起来的东西。这又非常卢梭。回归自然。这是回归自然。我的意思是，沙马说你实际上可以看到她裙子下的身体是什么样子，这当然与人们穿着的极其僵硬和结构化的裙子的情况不同。并不是说他们早些时候穿这些。他们是同时穿的。但她正在打破法国等级制着装的规则。绝对是。
Right. And not only that, she stops wearing corsets and stays and all those things that kind of really button you up. Again, it's very Russo. Go back to nature. It's going back to nature. I mean, Sharma says you can actually see what her body looks like under the dress, which of course is not the case with the incredibly rigid and structured dresses that people are wearing. It's not that they're wearing them earlier. They're wearing them at the same time. But she is breaking with the rules of French kind of hierarchical dress. Absolutely.
而且，我说过玛丽·安托瓦内特在某种程度上发明了现代时尚。她之所以这样做，是因为无论法国人怎么说，她都是法国王后。因此，她拥有欧洲女性中最高的知名度。但也因为她是这方面的天才。每天早上醒来，决定你想穿什么，你知道，你要穿什么衣服，你要怎么做头发，而不是按照僵硬的结构来规定，这是革命性的，你知道，字面意义上的革命性，因为这就是法国大革命期间将会出现的时尚风格。而玛丽·安托瓦内特，在某种程度上，我认为是法国作为时尚之都的现代声誉的教母。我们谈论了衣服。还有头发。所以
And, you know, I said that Marie Antoinette, in a way, invents modern fashion. And she does that because she is, whatever the French say, she is the Queen of France. For that reason, she has the highest profile of any woman in Europe. But also because she's a genius at it. And the idea of waking up every morning and just deciding what you want to wear, you know, what clothes you're going to have, how you're going to do your hair, rather than having it prescribed according to rigid structures is something revolutionary, you know, literally revolutionary, because this is the style of fashion that will come in during the French Revolution. And Marie Antoinette, to that extent, I think is the godmother of France's modern reputation as the home of fashion. And we've talked about clothes. There is also hair. So
有一本绝对精彩的书，书名很棒，叫《玛丽·安托瓦内特的头》，作者是威尔·巴肖，讲的是她的发型师，一个叫莱昂纳德先生的人，他将在整个故事中出现。同样，他是男性发型师而不是女仆，这非常非常令人震惊。他是位名人发型师，像贝尔坦夫人一样，可以随时见到她。所以这背后有一些非常非常深层的东西。我的意思是，这绝对是可辨认的。他为她设计了一系列令人难以置信的宏伟发型。所以玛丽·安托瓦内特最初推广的发型叫“感伤的蓬松发型”。感伤的蓬松。我的意思是，那是一个很难驾驭的句子，对吧？
there's an absolutely wonderful book with the great title, Marie Antoinette's Head by Will Bashaw, which is about her hairdresser, who is a man called Monsieur Léonard, who will feature throughout the story. And again, this is very, very shocking that he's a male hairdresser, not a lady's maid. He's a celebrity hairdresser and like Madame Bertin has ready access to her. So there's something very, very deeper about this. I mean, it's absolutely recognisable. And he gives her a whole succession of kind of unbelievably grandiose hairstyles. So the hairstyle that Marie Antoinette is initially promoting is called le pouf sentimental. The sentimental pouf. I mean, that's a hard sentence to carry
你可以想象那种梳起来的纱布、羽毛之类的东西。非常非常冒险，因为你知道，吊灯里有蜡烛。所以如果你擦到它，它可能会着火。而且有各种各样的风格。所以你有“刺猬头”，是不涂粉的头发。所以那是在回归自然。它们卷曲到发梢，层层叠叠地升起。所以它看起来像一只刺猬。有“西风”，是编织进头发里的花朵。所以同样，有一种从僵硬的礼节向自然过渡的感觉。然后在1781年，玛丽·安托瓦内特召见了莱昂纳德先生，她因为觉得自己正在脱发而心烦意乱。她的头发正在变稀疏。
off, right? You can imagine that kind of teased up gauze and plumes and things. Very, very risky because, you know, there are candles in the chandeliers. So if you brush against it, it might just go up in flames. And there are various kinds of styles. So you have the erisson, which is unpowdered hair. So that's kind of going back to nature there. And they're kind of curled to the tips and rising in tears. So it looks like an erisson, a hedgehog. There's the zephyr, which is flowers woven into the hair. So again, there's the sense that you're moving from kind of stiff formality to nature. And then in 1781, Monsieur Léonard is summoned by Marie Antoinette, who's distraught because she feels that she's losing her hair. Her hair is thinning.
莱昂纳德先生对此感到非常沮丧。他走开了，思考了一下。然后他回来做了件革命性的事，他剪短了她的头发，给了她一种“儿童发型”，他开始只用花朵而不是珠宝来装饰它，这创造了一种自然发型的时尚，是的，它传遍了凡尔赛宫，传遍了巴黎，传遍了法国，传遍了欧洲。她身边有很多人，不是吗？她有，你用了那个表达，她的“小队”，这听起来可能像泰勒·斯威夫特。但她确实有一个非常非常亲密的朋友圈子，她们后来会变得
And Monsieur Léonard is devastated by this. And he goes away and he thinks about it. And then he comes back and he does something revolutionary he cuts her hair he gives her the cafe a child's hairstyle he starts to decorate it only with flowers not with jewels and it creates this fashion for natural hairstyles yeah that spreads across versailles spreads across paris spreads across france spreads across europe and she has people who are around her, doesn't she? She has, you use the expression, her squad, which may sound like Taylor Swift. But she does have this coterie of very, very close friends who will later become,
像她一样充满争议，其中一些人，坦率地说，注定会有极其悲惨和血腥的结局。是的。特别是有两个。一个是波利尼亚克公爵夫人，我的意思是，她非常非常漂亮，举止优雅，绝对热爱八卦和阴谋。所以我认为这不太像泰勒·斯威夫特。更像是《贱女孩》里的“塑料姐妹花”，我知道你没看过，但我作为两个女儿的父亲，看过很多次。一部非常非常精彩的电影。我认为任何看过那部电影的人，如果你把玛丽·安托瓦内特和波利尼亚克公爵夫人看作是高中里的“塑料姐妹花”，她们是
like her, controversial, some of whom, frankly, are doomed to incredibly tragic and blood-curdling ends. Yes. So there are two in particular. There's the Duchess de Polignac, who, I mean, is very, very beautiful, exquisite manners, absolutely adores kind of gossip and intrigue. So I think it's kind of less Taylor Swift. It's more the plastics in Mean Girls, which I know you haven't seen, but which I, as a parent of two daughters, have seen a lot. A brilliant, brilliant film. And I think that anyone who's seen that film if you think of Mary Antoinette and the Duchess de Polignac as the plastics who were the
蜂王，然后还有这个总是试图让“fetch”这个词流行起来的跟班，但她从未成功，我认为那个角色会是朗巴尔亲王夫人，是的，她非常非常空虚。这是德·让利斯伯爵夫人对她极其刻薄的描述：她在谈话中从没有自己的观点，她总是采用那个被认为最机智的人的观点，方式非常独特。每当有严肃的讨论时，她从不说话，假装陷入恍惚。然后她会突然从沉思中醒来，逐字逐句地重复，好像那是来自
kind of the queen bees in a high school and then there's this sidekick who's always trying to make fetch happen the word fetch and she never does and I think that that character would be the process de lumbar yeah who is very very vapid this is the kind of brilliantly bitchy account of her by the comtesse de gemli she never had an opinion of her own in conversation she always adopted the opinion of the person who passed for the wittiest in a way that was utterly unique whenever there was a serious discussion she never spoke pretending to fall into a trance then she would suddenly appear to snap out of her reverie and repeat word for word as though it came from
她自己一样，刚才那个她决定采纳观点的人所说的话。她假装对别人刚刚说同样的话感到非常惊讶。她向每个人保证她没听说过。所以我认为你从中可以感觉到，玛丽·安托瓦内特喜欢这些人正是因为她们不机智。她们不聪明。她可以享受她们的陪伴。不可避免地，八卦会说她们都是女同性恋，她们都在进行萨福仪式。波利尼亚克公爵夫人尤其如此，她变得非常非常令人讨厌，但她们两个都非常不受欢迎。还有男性客人去小特里亚农宫，其中最臭名昭著的是一位叫阿克塞尔·冯·费尔森的潇洒瑞典军官，他是元帅的儿子，曾在1774年的歌剧院化装舞会上见过玛丽·安托瓦内特，
her what the person whose opinion she had decided to adopt had just said she affected affected great surprise when told someone had just said the same thing. She assured everyone she hadn't heard of it. So I think you get there a sense that Marie Antoinette likes these people precisely because they are not witty. They are not brilliant. She can enjoy their company. Inevitably, gossip will say that they're all lesbians, that they're all engaging in sapphic rites. The Duchess de Polignac in particular, who becomes widely, widely hated, but both of them are strongly disliked. There are also male guests going to the Petit Trianon, of whom the most notorious is a dashing Swedish officer called Axel von Fersen, who is the son of a field marshal and who had met Marie Antoinette at a mask ball at the opera in 1774
当时她还是王储妃，而他没认出她来，这显然对玛丽·安托瓦内特来说是一种巨大的刺激。是的，从那时起，经常的拜访，两人毫无疑问变得亲密起来。再次，人们理所当然地认为她们在睡觉。我认为这极不可能，因为这真的不是她的性格。你觉得？是的，这不是她的风格。是的，她那样做会很疯狂。但显然有一种对此的无视。我的意思是，有这些非常亲密的私人关系，是的，而且对凡尔赛宫的礼节和等级制度嗤之以鼻，推翻诺伊伯爵夫人所代表的一切。我的意思是，她是在给自己制造麻烦。她是。实际上，她哥哥约瑟夫二世有一句惊人的引语，
when she was still the dauphine and he hadn't recognized her which is obviously a kind of great thrill for marie antoinette yeah and from that point on the regular visits the two indisputably become close again it is taken for granted that they are sleeping i think this is most unlikely because it's not really in her character you think yeah it's not her style yeah and it would be mad for her to do that but there is clearly a kind of heedlessness about this i mean to have these kind of very close intimate relationships yeah and to kind of thumb her nose at the formalities and the hierarchies of versailles to bring down everything that the comtesse de noy had represented i mean she's building up trouble for herself. She is. There's an amazing quotation actually from her brother,
他写信给他们的兄弟利奥波德。他说：“她没有礼节。她出去，独自一人或与几个人一起跑来跑去，没有她身份的外在标志。她看起来有点不体面。虽然这对一个普通人来说还可以，但她没有做好她的工作。”
Joseph II, who wrote to their brother, Leopold. And he said, She has no etiquette. She goes out and runs around alone or with a few people without the outward signs of her position. She looks a little improper. And while this would be all right for a private person, she is not doing her job.
这就是问题所在，不是吗？她没有扮演法国人民所期望的法国王后的角色。不，她没有。而且我认为更重要的是，这对她来说更具破坏性的是，她实际上是在扮演情妇的角色。对，因为小特里亚农宫是情妇居住的地方，而王后不应该像情妇那样生活。所以随着路易十六统治进入1780年代，她开始像王后经常被憎恨的那样被憎恨，作为王室傲慢和专制主义的化身，但她也像宠臣一样被憎恨。你知道，她被塑造成一种贪婪、嗜血、性欲亢进的形象。
And that is the issue, isn't it? That she's not playing the part of a french queen as the french people expect no she's not and i think what is more and even more damaging for her is that she's actually playing the part of a mistress right because the petty trianon is where the mistress lives and queens are not supposed to live like mistresses so over the course of louis the 16th reign going into the 1780s she is she's coming to be hated as queens often are hated as kind of you know the embodiment of royal arrogance and of kind of absolutism but she's also being hated as favorites are you know she's being cast as a kind of a voracious, greedy, blood-sucking nymphomaniac.
而这两种形象正在融合，因为情妇总是被指责奢侈。是的。这是领地带来的，对吧？这就是她们在那里的原因。是的。而且令人惊讶的是，故事开始流传，玛丽·安托瓦内特实际上是以国家的名义，维持着一整缸水蛭，这是一种可怕的想法。
And the pair of these images are kind of being fused because a mistress is always being accused of extravagance. Yeah. Comes to the territory, right? That's what they're there to do. Yeah. And kind of amazingly, stories start to be repeated that Marie Antoinette is literally maintaining at the expense of the state, a whole tank full of leeches, which is a kind of horrible idea.
是的，一种隐喻，是的。而且，当然，情妇在性方面是滥交的。所以这就是为什么关于她有萨福恋情，和瑞典军官睡觉之类的故事。这就是为什么它们如此流行。关于这一点有趣的是，汤姆，罗伯特·丹顿·梅斯指出，它们始于1774年，也就是革命前15年，当时她才18、19岁。所以很早的时候，这些关于她有这种贪婪性欲的故事，关于她那个痴迷于锁的丈夫无法满足她，以及这种奢侈和堕落正在吸干法国的能量
Yeah, a sort of metaphor, yeah. And also, of course, mistresses are sexually promiscuous. And so this is why the stories that she's having, you know, sapphic affairs and sleeping with, you know, Swedish officers and things like that. It's why they have such currency. And the interesting thing about that, Tom, is that they start, I think it's Robert D'Anton Mace's point, that they start in 1774, so 15 years before the revolution, and when she's still only 18, 19 years old. So very early on, these stories that she has this kind of voracious sexual appetite, that her lock-obsessed husband is not satisfying, and that there's this kind of extravagance and depravity sucking the energy
和金钱的故事。它们开始得很早，不是吗？而且她永远无法摆脱它们。对。重申一下，因为我认为这非常重要，这些故事并非来自憎恨君主制的共和党人。它们来自她在宫廷里的竞争对手。正是这些人散布了这些谣言。它反映了你在宫廷中得到的放荡性格，路易十五曾体现过这种性格，你在拉克洛的伟大小说《危险关系》中也能看到，正如翻译给看过电影的人看的那样。我的意思是，整件事都是关于诱惑人们，认为贵族是残忍和性掠夺者的观点。当然，绝对体现这一点的作家是萨德侯爵，我们做过一期关于他的节目。在某种意义上，萨德侯爵正在重塑当时在色情作品中非常非常流行的思想。而玛丽·安托瓦内特，她曾拒绝与杜巴利夫人说话，因为她曾是交际花，她曾如此性欲不强，以至于婚姻七年都没有圆房。她成了色情幻想的主角，这些幻想在萨德侯爵的作品中越来越令人作呕和震惊。听众们可能想知道，这一切重要吗？这确实很重要，因为它威胁到了不仅是王后，还有国王和君主制本身的声誉。问题在于，在1780年代初，所有这些谣言、故事和幻想，它们缺乏一个明显的焦点。它们在地下。它们被宫廷竞争所渗透。
and the money out of France. They start very early, don't they? And she's never able to shake them. Right. And to reiterate, because I think this is so important, these stories are not coming from Republican people who hate the monarchy. It's coming from her rivals at the court. These are the people who are spreading it. And it reflects a character of libertinism that you get at the court, that Louis XV had exemplified, and which you get in Le Clos' great novel, Dangerous Liaisons, as it's translated to people who've seen the film. I mean, the whole thing is about debauching people, the idea that the aristocracy are cruel and sexually predatory. And of course, the writer who absolutely exemplifies this is the Marquis de Sade, who we did an episode on. And there's a sense in which the Marquis de Sade is reworking ideas that
但随后在1784年，发生了一场绝对的灾难，因为玛丽·安托瓦内特发现自己陷入了一场丑闻的火风暴中。实际上，多米尼克，这不仅仅是一场丑闻。这是一场风波。钻石项链事件。
are very, very current in pornography at the time. And Marie Antoinette, who had refused to speak to Madame du Barry because she'd been a courtesan, who had been so unsexually voracious that the marriage hadn't been consummated for seven years. She comes to be the protagonist of pornographic fantasies that are increasingly revolting and shocking in the way that the Marquis de Sade's writings are revolting and shocking. And listeners may be wondering, well, does any of this matter? And it does matter because it comes to threaten the reputation, not just of the queen, but of the king and of the monarchy itself. The thing is that in the early 1780s, all these rumors and stories and fantasies, they lack an obvious focus. They are underground. They are being percolated by court rivalries.
这是一个惊人的故事。这是一个绝对不可思议的故事。你明天会带我们了解这个，对吧？人们不必等待。是明天。是的。
But then in 1784, there's an absolute catastrophe because Marie Antoinette finds herself engulfed in a complete firestorm of scandal. And actually, Dominic, it's not just a scandal. It's an affair. The affair of the diamond necklace.
但到了1784年，发生了一场绝对的灾难，因为玛丽·安托瓦内特发现自己陷入了一场彻底的丑闻风暴。事实上，多米尼克，这不仅仅是丑闻，这是一起事件。钻石项链事件。
It's an amazing story. It is an absolutely incredible story. And you'll be taking us through this tomorrow, actually, won't you? People don't have to wait. It's tomorrow. Yes.
这是一个令人惊叹的故事。这绝对是一个不可思议的故事。明天你就会带我们了解这件事，对吧？大家不用等太久。就是明天。是的。
Because we're going to be running this series over the next two weeks. Now, if you want to hear about the Affair of the Diamond Necklace, and then we'll be getting into the calling of the States General, the fall of the Bastille, the course of the Revolution, the ideas behind the Revolution, and then the rising panic and terror of the King and Queen and their decision to flee France, which obviously ends up going wrong. If you want to listen to all that right away, you can do so by being a member of the Restless History Club.
因为我们将在接下来的两周内播出这个系列节目。如果你想了解钻石项链事件，随后我们将深入探讨三级会议的召开、巴士底狱的陷落、革命的进程、革命背后的思想，以及国王和王后日益增长的恐慌与恐惧，还有他们逃离法国的决定，当然，这个决定最终以失败告终。如果你想立即收听所有这些内容，可以通过成为“不安历史俱乐部”的会员来实现。
If you're not a member already, you can subscribe at therestesshistory.com. But Tom, thank you so much for that. I think there's only one expression, given that we are in 18th century France, that was a genuine tour de force. Thank you very much, Dominic. And on that bombshell, au revoir, everybody, and see you tomorrow. Bye-bye.
如果你还不是会员，可以在therestlesshistory.com订阅。汤姆，非常感谢你。鉴于我们身处18世纪的法国，我想只有一个词可以形容，那就是真正的杰作。非常感谢你，多米尼克。带着这个重磅消息，再见，各位，明天见。拜拜。
A de ma. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《余下皆娱乐》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前购买现场演出门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。